thank you for watching this video my
name is amri benelliasel
from harvard university and this is the
long video for the paper
limits of ordered graphs and their
applications
that appears in itcs 2021
this is joint work with eldar official
from the technion
amit levy from the university of
waterloo and yuichi yoshida from
nii japan
in this talk i will discuss limits of
graph sequences
typically one thinks about a sequence of
graphs that grow
larger and larger in terms of number of
vertices
and we wish to understand the underlying
structure
in a unified way the limit object
addresses this need for dense graphs
where the average degree is of the same
order as the number of vertices
the limit is called the graphon and its
theory
was established in a series of papers by
borgs chase
lovas sagadi shush and wester gombi
graph limits exhibit an analytical
perspective on graph theory
that has shown many benefits for various
applications
for example within tcs many property
testing results
are much cleaner and seem more natural
when stated and proved in analytical
language
we will see one such example in this
stock
in probability or statistics graphons
give rise to a nonparametric
model for distributions over graphs
which is also useful
in machine learning applications in
extremely graph theory again
the analytic perspective usually makes
things simpler and easier to prove
and here we will actually see an example
obviously in application areas where one
is interested in understanding the
properties of large graphs or networks
like statistical physics and the theory
of networks
graph fonts are also very relevant as
non-parametric models
to explain various phenomena
since the theory of dense graph limits
was established about 15 years ago
there has been lots of research on
limits for other combinatorial objects
a very popular line of work where here
only added
references to a few representative
central works
is on limits for sparse graphs where
unlike the notion of graphones
there is no one limit object that is
always correct and
the limit object has to be more problem
specific
a partial list of other combinatorial
objects for which
a limit object was already established
includes hyper graphs permutations high
dimensional
boolean functions partially ordered sets
and latin squares which are
two-dimensional generalizations
of permutations in this talk
i will establish the first known limit
object for dense ordered graphs
i will shortly explain what i mean by an
ordered graph
meanwhile i would like to mention that
the above mentioned work on
latin squares independently developed a
limit object for another type of
two-dimensional order structure
though its scope and applications are
different
a graph is ordered if its vertices have
a natural
ordering although one can also consider
other structural relations on the
vertices
for example an image can be seen as an
ordered bipartite graph
where one part corresponds to the rows
the other part corresponds to the
columns
and the edge color between row i and
column number j
corresponds to the pixel color in
location i
and j clearly the order of the rows and
columns is important for images
other relevant examples are temporal
graphs where
vertices represents events along some
timeline
and edges represent the interactions
between them
this is very relevant for example in
situations that
that involve sequential decision
decision making
basically this discussion is relevant
for any situation where the vertices
are not necessarily symmetric meaning
that they have some
underlying structure that must be
preserved
before discussing our limit theory for
ordered graphs
let us revisit the classical theory of
unordered graph limits
and describe its limit object the
graphone
first to formally define convergence we
need to define some space over functions
and describe how to represent finite
graphs
in this space for unordered graphs
we go through the following process we
take the end times and adjacency matrix
of the graph
where the row and column order does not
matter as we consider
unordered graphs and then we consider
a black and white board where each one
value
in the matrix corresponds to a one or
black pixel
in the board and each zero value in the
matrix
corresponds to a white pixel in the
board
now that we can describe graphs as
graphons
what would be a convergent sequence of
graphs
naturally we would want graphs with some
common behavior
to converge to a graph one that
characterizes this behavior
a natural candidate for describing the
behavior of a graph
is in terms of the subgraph densities
in other words a sequence of graphs
converges if for every fixed
subgraph f the density of
f in the graphs in the sequence
converges
here the density of f in g is the
probability that a random
sub graph of g with the same size of f
is equal to f
the limit graph one will have the same
sub frequencies
where here density is defined by
sampling a random subset of points
and for each pair of points we add an
edge between them
with probability proportional to the
value of the graphone
on this pair of vertices
as an example consider the sequence of
erdogan
random graphs g and one half
where the density of any unordered
subgroup from k
vertices converges to 2 to the minus k
times the size of the isomorphism class
of the subgraph therefore the sequence
converges to the
old one half graphene
this one
it's easy to check by definition that
the densities match
convergence of subgraph densities is a
notion that is hard to work with
and it turns out that a much more
natural notion of the cut distance
devised by
frieza and canon is equivalent and much
easier to work with
here the cut distance between a pair of
references roughly speaking
the maximum possible integral of the
graphone
over a rectangle which is the cartesian
product of two
labeled measurable subsets of reals
for example in a random graph
the integral over any rectangle with
non-zero
measure should typically equal one-half
the size of the rectangle which is the
same behavior
as the o1 half graphene
now what is needed to establish a limit
theory for
certain objects say for graphs first
we need a notion of representation for
finite objects
finite graphs in our case second we need
a usable notion of
distance between objects that would be
the cut distance
we already have these two components
in order for the analytical perspective
to make sense
that is that the notion of convergence
will be consistent and
interesting we need that the space of
limit objects
[Music]
paired with the distance function will
be a complete
space uh
by this i mean that any question
sequence any sequence of objects
whose pairwise distances converges to
zero
should converge to a limit
it would even be better if the space
would be compact
as compactness usually yields
regularity lemmas and other useful
applications
we also want the limit object to be as
simple as possible
without unnecessary overpresentation
finally for probabilistic purposes it
will be good to have a limit object
we can sample from this induces a
natural probability distribution
so can we use the graphone paired with
the cut distance
as the limit object for other graphs
again
like in the case of unordered graphs
here we assume closeness
under measure preserving transformations
this means the two graphs w and w prime
where w prime can be generated from w by
relabeling the points in a
measure-preserving way
should be the same this is the analytic
analog
of saying that the order of rows and
columns in an adjacency matrix
do not matter
the answer is negative consider the
following simple example
one ordered graph has a click on the
first
n over two vertices where i mean first
in terms of order
and there are no other edges except for
this
the edges of the click the other ordered
graph is the same
except that the click is on the last n
over two vertices
obviously these graphs are isomorphic
unordered graphs
so the graphing representations are
equivalent
however the ordered subreddit
frequencies
are not the same consider for example
the following ordered induced
subgraph having three vertices
and having the first two vertices
in terms of order connected and that's
it the other
the other pairs of vertices are not
connected on the right side graph
we do not have this subgraph at all so
the density is
zero on the left side
any sub graph generated by taking two
vertices from the first half
and one from the second half works
so the density will be three over eight
okay we see that allowing measure
preserving transformations
which made sense when considering
unordered graphs
doesn't make sense in the in the ordered
setting
what if we now use the same limit object
but without allowing such
transformations
this unfortunately also doesn't work
there is a sequence
of graphs that converge in terms of
ordered subgraph densities
but is not cauchy with respect to the
cut norm
this is the same as the cut distance but
we do not allow reordering
so it seems that the cut norm is just
not expressive enough
for the other case the sequence
is of the odd click graphs where
all odd number of vertices are connected
by an edge
and just for convenience we can also add
loops on odd vertices
although this doesn't really matter and
there are no other edges except for this
click
let us see a visual demonstration
so here are the odd click graphs on 4 6
8 and 10 vertices one can calculate and
see that the cut distance between
hn and h 2n
converges to one half so the sequence
diverges
in cut distance inserting cut norm
even though it clearly converges in
subgraph frequencies
so cut norm is not expressive enough
here
okay we want a distance function where
large enough
odd glitch graphs are close to each
other
so they form a question sequence because
they have a similar
ordered sub densities we want them to be
a question sequence
because we want them to converge trying
to understand what makes this graph
similar to each other note that if we
are able to
reorder the vertices very locally
without changing the order of the
vertices too much
we can turn the graph on representing hn
to the graphone
representing hm
uh quite easily so so our findings until
now are
as follows first allowing
arbitrary measure preserving bijections
is not suitable for the ordered setting
second no reordering at all
[Music]
results in the odd glitch examples being
far from each other in in the
distance in the cat norm
[Music]
that we use and
third slight reordering of the vertices
combines the best of both worlds odd
click examples
are close in when we
when when we are able to do some little
bit of reordering
but the counter example for arbitrary
measure preserving rejections
breaks down
so let us define the catch if distance
in the distance computation we do allow
measure preserving transformations
but the amount of reordering the
transformation applies
goes into the cost of the distance
function
would that be good enough
yes it turns out that the catch if
distance characterizes convergence
for all the graphs in the same way that
cut distance works for
unordered graphs now our graphs paired
with cut shift distance
good enough to represent ordered graphs
unfortunately the answer is negative if
we
revisit the or the click sequence we'll
need a sequence to converge
into a graph one that contains the same
amount of odd-like
and even like points in each interval
but this is not possible by the bag's
density theorem a classical result in
measure theory
which asserts that no measurable subset
of the reals
has density one-half in every interval
so we need a limit object that is more
expressive than a graphen
as we said for the odd clique example we
would like a limit object that can
contain the right proportion of odd
versuses and the right proportion of
even vertices
at any given point so instead of
considering
the two-dimensional graph which
allows us either lots of variability but
no sense of order
or a sense of order without enough
flexibility
we want a limit object that provides us
both order and
variability we call this limit object an
order
this is a function for pairs of points
in r
in r squared sorry to the interval
between 0 and 1. each pair contains one
coordinate
provides a sense of order and another
coordinate that provides
variability
recall that we need to say how finite
objects in our case
finite order graphs are represented as
an order run
here we will actually not use the the
variability coordinate
which will go into play only in the
limit object
the representing order on is a step
function where each vertex of the graph
is represented by an interval of
length one over n in the order
coordinate
here is a simple visual demonstration of
an order on
for each pair of order and variability
tuples
the order assigns a value
the catch if distance now allows measure
preserving transformations
that have some con some cost
in the order coordinate but
may be arbitrary in the variability
coordinate
now our first attempt would be to use
order runs as the limit object
coupled with the catch shift distance
and as you might expect this attempt
actually finally succeeds
the limit object for the odd click
sequence
will be one where for any value of x and
the order coordinate
half the variability interval consists
of odd particles
that belong to the click and the other
half consists of
even particles the value of the order on
between a couple of odd particles is
one this corresponds to an edge
and it is zero and on edge anywhere else
now let us state the main results of our
theory
the first result is the completeness is
the completeness theorem
which states that in the space of
orderance any question sequence in
catchy's distance
is an ordinary limit in particular this
means that
any sequence of ordered graphs with the
convergence
ordered subgraph densities has a limit
in the order on space
which demonstrates the same subgraph
frequencies
the second result asserts that the space
is not only complete
but also compact every sequence of
orderance has a converging subsequence
an equivalent formulation is that any
collection of open balls in this space
has a finite subset which covers the
space
this is useful for obtaining regularity
lemma type results
and we will actually see one such result
soon
the next result is a sampling theorem
which considers the following sampling
procedure take k
points of the form x i and a
i in deodorant and consider
a random ordered graph on k vertices
where the probability for an edge
between vertices number i and j
is the value of the order one between x
i and a i
and the other point x j and a j
then with high probability the sample
graph is close
in catching distance to the to the
original order on
an immediate corollary of the sampling
theorem is the density theorem
which states that for any order on there
is a finite ordered graph
that is arbitrarily close
in catching distance to it specifically
if you want
distance epsilon then there exists such
a graph of size
exponential in one over epsilon
the last and perhaps most interesting
main result that i would like to mention
is the pixelization lemma
let us define a pixelized order on as a
finite description order one that has
k types of order blocks and l types of
variability strips and the value of the
edge between a pair of tuples
corresponds only to the block and strip
pair that each of them belongs to this
is actually a slightly
simplified picture of the actual
definition so
feel free to see the paper for more
details
the pixelization theorem now states that
any order one
is arbitrarily close in l1 distance to a
pixelized order on
with the added property that any
subgraph that does not appear with
positive density in the original odorant
will also have zero density in the
pixelized one
conceptually this is basically a strong
analytic
ordered regularity lemma for older ones
it means that any euler one can be
approximated
with small l1 error
by a finite description order on without
any additional noise
so without any artifacts that
appear in the original order
let me remark here that being close in
l1 distance
trivially means also being close in cut
distance so
this statement does not follow from any
of the previous
results and in fact this result
requires some additional tools to prove
it
now let me conclude with a couple of
applications of applications of our
theory
the first application is a new proof of
the ordered graph removalemma
that we recently approved with the
london fisher
the mova lemma considers hereditary
properties of
ordered graphs whereby hereditary i mean
a property that is closed under deletion
of vertices
for example being by
bipartite or not containing an induced
copy of a cyclone for vertices
c4 and
the removal element states that any
hereditary
ordered graph property is testable with
a constant number of queries
this is a substantial generalization of
well-known graph removal lemmas that
do not take order into account
the original proof of the audio graph
removal lemma
is complicated it's it's more
combinatorial in nature
and it mixes several golde type ideas
with
flow based surrounding rounding
techniques and
a new type of ramsey lemma that is
robust to noise
the new proof that we were able to get
using
or using order on using ordered graph
limits
look much simpler than the combinatorial
proof
and this new proof uses compactness
pixelization
and in addition just a standard ram
dilemma
it's also much shorter as i mentioned in
the beginning of the talk
there are many situations where the
analytic perspective is
more natural and leads to simpler proofs
this is one such example of this
phenomenon
the other application concerns an
interesting line of work in
experimental combinatorics given any
hereditary property of unordered graphs
and another graph one can ask what is
the hamming distance between the graph
and the data property
this is the minimum number of edges that
we need to add or delete in the graph
to satisfy the property a beautiful and
surprising result by a lone and star
shows that for unordered graphs for any
eradicator property
there exists a probability p so there
exists some probability p
depends on the property so that
so that the erdogan a random graph model
gnp
generates with high probability graphs
that are simple
asymptotically differ the furthest away
from the property
for example for the property of not
containing an induced copy of
c4 the cycle of on four vertices
it is easy to see that any graph is of
hamming distance at most one half to the
property
but it also turns out that gn one-half
is typically almost one-half far from
the property
and one may naturally ask the same
question in
audio graphs
the bad news are that this theorem is no
longer true for older graphs
there is an example of such an ordered
property
where gnp is at most one quarter far
while the furthest ordered graph from
the property is actually almost one half
far
however the good news are that we do
prove a weaker but
more general version of the unordered
result
that works for old graphs this is the
first result of this type
what we show is that for any hereditary
property of ordered graphs
there exists an order stochastic block
model
which generates ordered graphs that are
asymptotically the furthest
away from the property here stochastic
block model is a very well known
generalization of
this ready of the erdos training model
where there are constant number of types
of vertices
and each vertex is randomly assigned a
type
then each pair of vertices is randomly
connected by an edge
with probability that only depends on
the pair of types considered
by ordered i mean the types corresponds
to intervals
in the ordering of the vertices
that's it for today let me state several
interesting questions left for future
research
first we focused on more combinatorial
applications of
the ordered graph limitary and we did
not look into probabilistic or
statistical models that
odorants naturally induce i mean we did
we did prove
the sampling theorem as one of our main
theorems but we didn't explore it any
further
this would this should be interesting
for generative
for generative models in applications
like temporal or causal graphs
where there is an underlying order on
the vertices that
graphones or other limit objects cannot
directly capture
another interesting line of research is
to develop limit objects for ordered
structures
that are less the the limit objects are
less global
in nature our limit object is suitable
for dense ordered graphs
it's it's more no it's it's more global
in nature
and it would be interesting to look into
models that are sparse or
more local in terms of the ordering
the sparse line of research is very
active
for unordered graphs as we mentioned
before
okay thank you for it for your attention
feel free to drop an email if you have
any questions or to
talk at the conference see you